I think you guys are going to like this one.
Donald Trump and everybody around him are
denying, knowing this guy Lev Parness and
they're all ending up in pictures with left
Parness that are leaking very quickly.
The name love Parness has become a pretty
important name in the Trump Ukraine fiasco.
Not yet a household name, but maybe soon.
I'll remind you the sort of chain of command.
Donald Trump hired Rudy Giuliani as his personal
attorney.
One of the things that Rudy Giuliani did was
get ambassador Marie Ivana [inaudible] quote
out of the way for Donald Trump.
That's the way Rudy put it when he was interviewed
recently.
And the way that Rudy Giuliani partially got,
uh, Maria Bonovitch out of the way was with
the help of two henchmen.
Lev Parness and Igor Fruman.
Both have since been indicted.
Fruman is not visibly cooperating, left Parness
visibly very much cooperating with documents
and files and recordings and all sorts of
stuff.
And for a while Republicans have been saying,
we don't know that guy.
We have no idea who this guy is.
More recently, documents revealed that left
Parness was involved in putting physical surveillance
on Marie Evanovich in Ukraine.
He did an interview with Rachel Maddow saying
everyone around Trump knew what it was that
was going on.
Penn.
Everybody knew.
It was also confirmed, as I told you last
week, that despite Devin Nunez, denials left
Parness and Devin Nunez did communicate by
phone.
Devin Nunez miraculously remembering that
last week has loved Parness released documents.
So now everybody around Trump is panicked
and they're immediately scrambling to save
left party.
No, I don't, I don't know the guy.
No idea who you're talking about.
So let's go through it step by step and dig
into the brazen and bold nature of the lies
that they are telling you.
Here's Donald Trump himself saying, I don't
know the guy.
Thank you.
Good questions.
What is your response to web partners who
said your Robert's in your brain?
We're all about 2020.
We just wanted Joe by now.
Well, I don't know him.
I don't know.
Part of this other than I guess I had pictures
taken, which I do with thousands of people,
including people today that I didn't meet,
but uh, just met them.
And as Trump mentions, yes, there are pictures.
Here is a picture of Donald Trump with left
Parness back in 2014 and as Donald Trump says,
this is not proof that anything more than
a picture with a random person was taken,
but it's a little different than, Oh, do you
know this body shop owner in Missoula?
No.
Well, here's a picture of you with him when
you went to a rally in Missoula.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, I met him when swinging through because
it just so happens that we have another picture
with Trump and Parness and partners with Ivanka
and partners with Jared Kushner and partners
with Trump advisor, Kellyanne Conway and partners
with the vice president Mike Pence and Parness
with Donald Trump jr and Parness with Eric
Trump.
And on and on and on.
But there's even more because it's not just
Trump and multiple pictures with left Parness
Trump said it's okay for his own personal
lawyer to represent Lev Parness and Igor Fruman.
Here is an email which we now have.
We're Donald Trump's lawyer.
Jay Sekulow writes to another Trump lawyer,
John Dowd, and says, I spoke to Trump.
It's okay for you to represent Parness and
Fruman Trump pictured okay with shared representation
but doesn't know the guy.
And of course Parness was all over the Trump
administration.
Here's another picture with Donald Trump and
another picture with Parness.
I think you get the idea.
Kellyanne Conway then went on CNN and insist
that she doesn't know the guy either at what
Lev Parness says and what the documents show
and what the president asks.
And the summary while the president does,
and I say that he did go wrong, he wrote in
a hotel note that Cuomo was talking about
what Lev Parness said, not whether Kellyanne
Conway knows him and she says, I don't know
him.
And here is a picture of Kellyanne with Lev
Parness, vice president Mike Pence, issuing
a similar denial saying, I don't know the
guy.
Of course there are pictures of them together
as well.
But the real point with Pence is that Lev
Parness is alleging that Pence knew what was
being done in Ukraine and whether Mike Pence
does or doesn't know love Parness is not relevant
to whether Mike Pence knew what was being
done with Ukraine.
And of course every indication, every allegation
is that he did.
One more cherry on top here.
There's been this very corrupt relationship
between Donald Trump and a woman named Pam
Bondi for many years.
Pam Bondi is the former attorney general of
Florida who was starting to investigate Trump
university that total scam sham, uh, money
money grab that Donald Trump participated
in years ago called Trump university.
And Pam Bondi abruptly stopped investigating
Trump university around the same time that
Donald Trump donated $25,000 to her campaign
for reelection.
Pam Bondi just so happens has recently joined
Donald Trump's defense team.
We'll get to more about that later.
And here's a picture of her with Lev Parness.
This is the guy who was managing physical
surveillance of a sitting us ambassador, and
they all know him.
So here's the deal.
They all know him to some degree.
The exact degree is not really important.
Left Parness isn't, has been around Trump
and the people around him.
For awhile, he has had access.
He was doing insane things as a henchman for
Donald Trump's lawyer.
The idea that Trump is are excusing a president,
having his personal lawyer through private
investigators put an ambassador under physical
surveillance and they are saying the real
problem here is Joe Biden and Hunter Biden
and Barisma is extraordinarily disturbing.
Now last sort of word of caution here, the
left has to be careful about accepting everything
left Parness as if it's true.
Left partners appears to be a crook who did
a lot of dirty work for Republicans.
He's now in huge trouble.
He's coming out, he's telling the truth, he's
copying to tons of misdeeds and we'll accept
it with a skeptical eye.
It's similar to when Michael Cohen turned
on Donald Trump and all of a sudden there
were people on the left who said, this guy,
everything he's saying can be trusted.
100% no, he's in huge trouble and to some
degree he probably realizes the error of his
ways in a sense, but these are individuals
who for a very long time, while the going
was good, they kept on going with no problem
whatsoever.
So it's important not to immediately think
that a guy with a life of sketchy behavior
is suddenly our best friend because his back
is up against the wall and he's lawyered up
and he's turning on Donald Trump.
I'm sure that much of what left partners is
saying is true, but let's not make him into
our hero.
Uh, and hang the case against Donald Trump
strictly on what Lev partner says.
This rarely works out well for anybody including
Democrats in the left.
We'll continue talking about this on Instagram.
Oh, excuse me.
Follow me there
at David dot Pacman.
Follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
at David tack intro.
We'll be back right after this short break